une envie d'être actrice comme ça au
départ ou c'est non pas du tout il y
avait le hasard et le hasard pendant
longtemps jusqu'à ce que je rencontre
enfin pendant longtemps non pendant deux
ans et ça joue et comment le rct après
tout c'est un métier ennuis non c'est
pas ça faisait du cinéma qu'il avait
l'air très très heureuse qu'elle était
très passionné que sans doute à travers
ses yeux ça me semble à une chose
possible de moi même tout seul j'en
aurais sûrement jamais fait j'étais trop
timide la timidité à passer quand avec
jacques demy au nom pas tout de suite
dont elle a passé et longtemps après et
a disparu maintenant pas complètement
mais enfin beaucoup moins mais ça sent
encore je trouve que les espèces de
faune de timidité ou 2 tab alors oui il
m'a posé la question je viens les crocs
ce nom mais on a un peu l'impression
toujours que donc même s'il reconnaît
les réponses c'est comme intéressant les
vergers de trouver toujours quand vous
écouterez toujours un peu indécent
d'être en train de jouer la commune
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose de moi
qui refusent oui oui ça c'est vrai je
sais que c'est vrai ça dans tous les
films
non il des films où je me pose pas la
question dans le film de truffaut par
exemple dans le dernier métro j'étais
vraiment je me suis jamais poser ce
genre de questions parce que parce qu'on
passe que vous pouvez contrôler
parfaitement tout ce que vous faites
non parce que à cause du personnage de
là
du film du sujet de l'époque tout ça je
ne sais pas c'était j'ai jamais ce genre
de réserve quand on est une personne
bien élevés c'est normal d'avoir des
réserves forex et bien élevé
c'est-à-dire une espèce de refus absolu
fondamentale du minimum
d'exhibitionnisme ou 2 ou de se montrer
sur scène que suppose le fait de jouer
il ya des acteurs qui adore c'était
parce que quand vous en parler c'est
immédiatement ne revient en effet que
l'aspect que je n'aime pas ça c'est vrai
pour moi faire un film c'est une c'est
plus une certaine façon de vivre des
choses de ces oui c'est beaucoup plus
romanesque de toute ma vie que mais
quand vous le raconter comme ça c'est
vrai que tout ça le côté exhibitionniste
tout ça ça me oui je dis pas tellement
avec tout ça parce que finalement le
moment on tourne vraiment par rapport à
une année de travail c'est tellement
course est tellement relatif donc
peut-être que mon jeu tourne vraiment
c'est pas le moment où j'ai le plus de
plaisir que lille même si j'ose de monde
mais entre le projet l envie de tourner
avec elle qu'à la lecture d'un scénario
qui vous plaît le fait d'en parler c'est
une c'est une façon de vivre sa vie
jouer n'est peut-être pas le moment
culminant en tous les cas pas toujours
je peux une vraie actrice si c'est vrai
je vous assure c'est vrai non non je le
dire rires mais c'est vrai alors pour
reprendre des lieux communs il ya les
actrices qui sont des vraies actrices
qui ne sont jamais des stars même il ya
une chose en tous les cas c'est que moi
je veux être heureuse dans mon métier et
que c'est vrai que j'ai des images assez
difficile à supporter marmande j'ai vu
trop de pages est pas connu de près mais
j'ai trop d' image d'actrice malheureuse
c'est vrai que je me défends beaucoup
sans doute pour ne pas être trop
malheureuse
pas pour être heureuse mais pour ne pas
être trop malheureuse
[Musique]
je ne me sens pas faisant partie d'une
génération je ne me sens pas je ne me
sens pas aussi jeune que je le devrais
et je me sens même temps plus bas âge et
aux plus jeunes que je ne le suis je
suis pas tout à fait à l'aise dans cette
histoire de génération sans doute parce
que moi j'ai eu un enfant très jeune et
que j'étais très jeune à l'époque je
vivais avec des gens d'une autre
génération
[Musique]